it was the moment the war in Ukraine
spread Beyond its borders undersea
sabotage on pipelines in the Baltic the
attacks on Nordstrom were blamed by the
West at the time in September on Russia
now Western intelligence is accusing a
freelance group of ukrainians with links
to the government in Kiev its officials
are denying involvement and still
accusing Russia of being responsible
they cut Supply in Ukraine so the next
logical step would be to cut half of
Supply somewhere else
that is why in my opinion just the half
of these pipelines were blown up the
pipelines were built to carry gas from
Russia to Europe via Germany leaks were
reported on the Nordstrom 2 pipeline
first then a day later more were
discovered on nordstream one now more
than four months later German
intelligence reportedly claims a wealthy
Ukrainian harder yacht explosives and
divers to launch the attacks
Germany's defense minister was drawing
the dots to Kiev while urging against
jumping to conclusions
I know the reports about this
investigation I read that with great
interest and we have to distinguish
clearly yes whether it was a Ukrainian
group so it could have been on Ukrainian
behalf or a pro-ukrainian one without
the knowledge of the government but I
caution against jumping to conclusions
the claims come after Germany's decided
to send tanks to Ukraine overcoming
public reluctance
analysts say Ukraine will need to tread
carefully now if I was in key even
trying to game this the issue of uh with
assuming the story is true which it
looks pretty credible what we're hearing
today okay what is this now going to do
to Germany will they start dragging
their feet on supplying more tanks more
ammunition and so forth Germany is slash
or soon will be
um Ukraine's biggest European supplier
of equipment you don't really want to be
annoying Germany with let's call it
freelance activity there is an
information War underway the sources are
all unnamed but the story can only
complicate relations between Ukraine and
its allies as the war moves into another
year Dominic wagorn Sky News